bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
l'inattendu le nouveau magazine de
france info préparé en collaboration
avec la rédaction de nina chaque semaine
nous allons faire un bond dans le temps
pour vous aider à mieux comprendre notre
actualitté contemporaine celle
inattendue vous êtes sur france info et
vous êtes les bienvenus là monsieur
bonsoir je voudrais regarder la france
au fond des yeux répété que gm a trait à
tricoter d'accord là dessus trop plat
cela ramènerait un peu moins mais si
vous ne réussissez pas à ce qu'il vous
manque une seule chose un tout petit
détail le truc c'est
ce qui lui arrive à la gueule
là pour vous aider à comprendre
l'actualité d'aujourd'hui nous allons
donc faire un bond dans le temps en
compagnie de géraldine et de tarik
journalistes à li na bonjour à tous les
deux on appelle vous avez décortiquer
les titres de la presse certains sujets
ont plus particulièrement retenu votre
attention on voit parfois dans les
archives de la télévision et bien que
l'histoire bégaie tariq l'annnonce du
plan de relance du gouvernement cette
semaine vous a interpellé ainsi que la
nomination de françois bayrou au poste
de haut commissaire au plan voilà donc
ces capitaines bayrou un françois bayrou
maire de pau président du modem en
quelque sorte ressuscité par la macro ni
pour occuper ce poste de haut
commissaire au plan et à la prospective
sa mission c'est de dessiner le futur de
la france où le plan social économique
pour les dix ou vingt prochaines années
ce haut commissariat nathanaël il a été
mis en sommeil au début des années 90
mais je me suis demandée depuis quand
est ce qu il a dit vous avez une idée ça
me rappelle vaguement quelques cours de
troisième mais c'était il ya longtemps
on va revenir bien des décennies en
arrière en
1946 il s'agissait de redresser la
france d'après-guerre aux manettes nous
avons un des pères fondateurs de
l'europe il s'agit de jean monnet on
écoute tout de suite en présence de
monsieur georges bidault monsieur jean
monnet a présenté le plan de quatre ans
oeuvre collective le plus de 1000
personnes fonctionnaires agriculteurs
striée les syndicalistes ouvriers le
papa les programmes fixe au cas où ce
qui passionne les six activités de base
ce qui positionne d'ensemble de
l'économie est solidement le charbon et
les principes et la sidérurgie le ciment
les machinistes à greta les traces par
la callas charbon sidérurgie ciment
c'était vraiment une autre époque un
nathanel je doute que françois bayrou
puisse trouver l'inspiration dans nos
archives darek ne sous-estimé pas la
force des archives de l'ina autre info
qui a retenu votre attention géraldine
l'annnonce de jean michel blanquer d'un
grenelle des professeurs c'était
dimanche dernier pourquoi avez vous fait
ce choix dernier oui un grenelle 1 pour
améliorer le bien-être au travail car
selon le ministre il s'exprimait donc
dans le jdd m heureux ce sont des élèves
heureux ce bien-être passerait par une
revalorisation salariale et ça nathanaël
ça m'a fait penser à une archive de 1981
parce que dans ces années là les profs
commencent à dénoncer un malaise ambiant
déjà les mêmes revendications manque de
considération manque de rémunération
écoutez cet instituteur qui témoignait
notre image comme elle est à l'image de
notre salaire c'est à dire qu'il s'est
réellement dévalorisé beaucoup de
parents sont très étonnés lorsque l'on
est en parlant on est nombreux je leur
donne mon salaire
[Musique]
notre tâche consiste à préparer demain
avec les enfants d'aujourd'hui mais avec
souvent des moyens deviennent une telle
et non un certain la longueville locaux
qui vient encore de jules ferry il ceci
pose problème pour faire une pédagogie
de l'an 2000
alors on va continuer à parler de la
rentrée mais cette fois du côté des
enfants un retour à l'école forcément
particulier un sou le psy de l'hygiène
un dossier sensible pour les de
l'éducation nationale et ça t'arrive ça
ne date pas d'hier la propreté plus que
jamais mais déjà par le passé on a
essayé de sensibiliser nos enfants à la
plus de propreté 1 ça m'a fait penser à
une archive des années 50 alors dans
cette archive on y voit un concours
national de la propreté c'est très
sérieux s'étaient lancés par les
ministres de la santé et de l'éducation
nationale tous les écoliers de france
pouvait participer il suffisait de
rédiger une dissertation sur les joies
de l'eau et du savon le tout pour gagner
quoi à votre avis je prends une boîte de
chocolats enfin j'ai bien hâte à noël on
va le découvrir ensemble dans ce
document de 1956
très jeunes lauréats ont joué les ags
accord devant les représentants des
ministres de l'éducation nationale et de
la santé publique faute de lingots d'or
on remettait leur poids de sa volt
toilettes aux enfants les plus propres
de france vainqueur parmi cinq cent
mille écoliers du concours national de
la propreté
[Musique]
on n'a pas une raison pour buller à
l'école bien sûr ça c'était pour l'actu
de la semaine mais sinon que s'est il
passé le 2 septembre ces dernières
années on remonte le temps avec le
zapping de l'ina ça s'est passé à 2
septembre c'était en france où un peu
partout dans le monde regardez
bonjour
une image une simple image peut-elle
modifier la perception des choses et le
2 septembre au matin à bord du cuirassé
missouri ancré dans la baie de tokyo le
général ma carte et accompagner les
représentants de toutes les armées
alliées vient à peine de monter quand à
khost une vedette
voici ce qu'ils vont signer la
capitulation totale des nazis d'extrême
orient celle que vous allez découvrir a
provoqué une onde de choc en europe le
parti communiste lui perd des forces
tandis que l'extrême droite ne cesse
d'en gagner
[Applaudissements]
merci de cet aveu elle est dure elle est
difficile à soutenir mais nous avons
choisi nous aussi de vous la montrer
comme la plupart des journaux du
continent celle d'un jeune enfant très
jeune sans vie sur une plage un enfant
syrien morts noyés après un naufrage ce
matin c'est avec seulement 30 petites
secondes de retard sur l'horaire que
s'est posée le sou news à l'atterrissage
parfait le seuil où s'est posée bien
droit à la verticale claudie rayonnante
c'est cliché de dire ça mais c'est
précisément le type de photos dont on
dit qu'elle vaut plus que mille mots
cette image fait changer la nature du
débat sur un glacier 600 personnes nus
comme des vers pour dénoncer le
réchauffement climatique elles ont posé
devant l'artiste américain spencer
tunick au final une installation
artistique est un moyen de pression
politique le pape sa bille de verre vous
allez le voir et ce n'est pas seulement
un choix vestimentaire
benoît 16 a adressé un message
écologiste inédit aux cinq cent mille
jeunes rassemblés ce week-end au
sanctuaire de lorette larmes au bras les
américains poule le seul ennemi est le
premier drapeau américain monte dans le
ciel du japon un mac arthur grandit
encore par la victoire en descente
aujourd'hui le monde entre dans la paix
ce soir et à demain
voilà pour ce zapping toutes les
semaines l'inattendu va également
approfondir un dossier de l'actualité
contemporaine en remontant dans le temps
un bond de quelques années en arrière
qui offrent parfois souvent un éclairage
supplémentaire aux événements récents
aujourd'hui nous partons aux états unis
avec ce drame survenu à kenosha dans le
wisconsin regardez et écoutez c'était il
ya seulement dix jours
jacob black 29 ans est grièvement blessé
par des policiers lors de son
interpellation on a clairement entendu
cette détonation cet incident intervient
trois mois après la mort par asphyxie de
georgetown légalement lors de son
interpellation l'image a déclenché des
émeutes et des manifestations tariq
c'est un nouvel épisode de violences
policières perpétrés contre des noirs
aux états unis mais c'est un épisode de
plus aux états unis qui sont
régulièrement secouées à part ce type de
violences policières je vous propose de
revenir sur quelques grandes dates au
fil de nos archives on commence avec
1965 c'est la date de l'année de la
première affaire médiatisée nous sommes
à los angeles au mois d'août dans le
quartier noir de watts un automobiliste
est arrêté une arrestation musclée qui
vire à un affrontement entre policiers
et riverains suivi d'une semaine de
manifestations
je vous propose un extrait à ce sujet il
a été diffusé dans le magazine
d'information cinq colonnes à la une des
journalistes français est allé couvrez
les incidents sur place notons le
nathanel parce que en général pour ces
événements nous travaillons nous les
rédactions avec des images envoyées par
des chaînes américaines on regarde
c'était en 1965 cela a commencé par peu
de choses un incident de circulation qui
normalement n'auraient même pas mérité
une ligne dans les journaux un policier
blanc qui interpelle un automobiliste
mais l'automobiliste était un noir ce
fut l'émeute la plus sanglante aux cris
de mort à l'homme blanc il eu des
milliers de blessés
32 morts et il fallut une semaine à une
armée de 15000 hommes pour rétablir
l'ordre vous dites une émeute j'appelle
ça une révolte sociale
voilà pour cet extrait de cinq colonnes
à la une premier magazine d'information
lancée en 1959 par darcy des groupes et
lazareff tariq on assiste à ce moment là
à la première médiatisation de la
violence policière contre à la
communauté afro-américaine aux états
unis et ça continue à deux ans plus tard
nous sommes à l'été 1967 qu'on appelle
le long crottes summer le long était
chaud et cette fois ce sont des
incidents qui intervient dans tout le
pays ils sont suivies d'émeutes ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que ces violences
policières nathanel elle s'ajoute à un
contexte déjà tendu un pour les
communautés noires entre discriminations
en tous genres chômage mal logement
alors forcément ces violences font
éclater la colère
c'est le résultat de longues années de
frustration
de dépravation
les jeunes ne veulent plus endurer
seconde génération a connu
il convient de voir les faits de
violence contre des hommes noirs sont
dénoncés dans les médias y at il un
moment où les auteurs ont été acquittés
non rarement en tout cas c'est
d'ailleurs l'un dés motifs de cette
colère on va prendre un exemple en 1981
à miami deux policiers accusés de viol
et de meurtre sur des noirs sont
acquittés alors à défaut de justice la
communauté réagi avec violence elle
assume comme cet homme qu'on écoute tout
de suite appelé d'un je crois qu'il
fallait faire et
pourquoi
vous ne pouvez pas brutaliser un chien
très longtemps ça qu'ils se mettent à le
mordre
à l'autre race doit en subir
et si on n'avait pas répondu comme on
l'a fait les blancs auraient continué à
se conduire comme ça
voilà des actes et des affaires de
racisme qui prennent un tournant
particulier dans les années 90 pour lui
et ce grâce à ça regardez le film
amateur on y voit sur ces images des
violences filmées sur le vif ce qu'on
regarde assez remonte à 1991 on voit
clairement un policier taper sur un
homme il s'agit de rené king 56 coups de
matraque pour un simple excès de vitesse
l'image est forte vous voyez bien elle a
touché l'opinion pas seulement la
communauté noire il est aussi des stars
qui ont rejoint les mouvements de
protestation mais malgré cette pression
de la société nathanel malgré la
puissance de ces images les policiers
ont été acquittés alors l'histoire elle
s'est encore une fois répété encore une
vague d'émeutes violentes et toujours
ces mêmes images un vous voyez des
flammes des pillages et intervention
musclée de la garde nationale alors si
on résume au regard de toutes ces
archives peu de condamnations une colère
qui dure et des affrontements
malheureusement récurrent exactement et
donc cette contestation elle se répèter
à force forcément à l'adapt des codes
notamment des slogans le tout premier
slogan c'est notre justice ne puisse pas
de justice pas de paix on le voit depuis
les années 80 l'autre c'est aykan bolide
ce qui veut dire je n'arrive plus à
respirer énormément repris depuis 2014
2014 qui est l'année de la mort d'éric
garner cet homme qui a perdu la vie et
tout fait alors qu'il était plaqué au
sol par des policiers
les mêmes options d'ailleurs été répétée
par giorgio floyd en mai dernier enfin
un slogan black live matters en fait
nathanel ces mots viennent d'un
collectif le nom d'un collectif contre
le racisme créé en 2013 on le voit
ensuite apparaître dans les slogans des
manifestations dès 2014 blacklight
matters est même repris jusqu'en france
surtout depuis le mouvement de
protestation contre les violences
policières initiée par assa traoré assa
traoré la soeur inde adama traoré est
décédé à la suite de son arrestation par
la police merci beaucoup tarik pour cet
éclairage autres grands titres de
l'actualité le début du tour de france
trois semaines d'efforts
3480 km 176 coureurs et est basé rohff
sommes pas dans le peloton en tout cas
le tour de france est une compétition
100% masculine ça n'a pas toujours été
le cas on va en reparler dans un instant
puisque la fédération internationale de
cyclisme promet une grande boucle
féminine en 2022 en attendant où sont
les femmes du vélo français pour
répondre à cette question claire flore
et bonjour alors vous êtes une cycliste
éclairé par fessionnels mais qui
pratiquent ce sport à un très haut
niveau et vous avez lancé en 2015
l'association donnons des ailes aux
vélos qu'est ce que c'est que cette
association quel est son objectif
effectivement il s'agit d'un projet de
femmes qui souhaitent faire la promotion
du cyclisme féminin donc depuis
maintenant six ans nous sommes treize
femmes à parcourir la france on réalise
les mêmes étapes que le tour de france
masculins mais un jour avant
exceptionnellement cette année un mois
avant étant donné le contexte est donc
l'idée c'est vraiment de d'agir pour
l'organisation d'une grande course par
étapes féminines qui serait l'équivalent
du tour de france masculins alors
pourquoi cette obsession par rapport au
tour de france par rapport à une course
à étapes est ce que c'est vraiment une
course à part comme l'est déjà pour les
hommes qu'est ce qu'elle apporterait au
peloton féminin le tour de france c'est
vraiment la course par excellence qui
fait rêver c'est un symbole ça fait
partie des droits des trois grands tours
qui existent donc on a le tour d'italie
le tour de france et le tour d'espagne
c'est un des événements les plus
médiatisés au monde donc c'est
évidemment une grande caisse de
résonance pour le cyclisme féminin et
d'avoir ça veut dire quoi médias égale
argent sans média pas d'argent donc pas
de championne est ce que vous êtes sûr
que les médias suivrait une compétition
comme celle là oui c'est une évidence on
l'a vu avec la coupe du monde féminine
de football le public est intéressé par
le sport féminin mais il faut lui donner
envie en en diffusant déjà dans un
premier temps pour le moment non diffuse
très peu évidemment qui dit fusion dit
visibilité dix partenaires et 10 argent
donc structuration comment vous
expliquer le manque de mixité
aujourd'hui dans le cyclisme et bien si
je pense que c'est un problème de
visibilité moi je viens pas du milieu du
vélo et en fait je me rendais pas compte
qu'il y avait pas de tour de france
féminin jusqu'à ce qu'on attire mon
attention au dessus et je me suis dit
qu'en fait c'était peut-être là le souci
si on ne voit pas ça n'existe pas donc
un tour de france féminin où une grande
course par étapes en tout cas médiatisés
ce serait la garantie d'une visibilité
et donc d'identification de la part des
jeunes filles à dire quoi ce sont les
grandes championnes des grandes courses
qui donne envie aux petites filles de 6
et temps de remonter sur un vélo et
d'aller voir les clubs ou au contraire
ce sont les clubs qui doivent
dire bah tiens on est là et le vélo
c'est facile ça ne s'oublie pas pour moi
ces deux choses a mené en parallèle à la
fois l'accueil dans les clubs parce que
c'est aussi un souci actuellement on n'a
pas l'habitude d'accueillir les femmes
elles sont souvent isolés dans leur club
et je pense aussi qu'il faut qu'on ait
des images qui donnent envie qui inspire
et les grandes championnes qu'on
pourrait voir dans le cadre d'une course
bien médiatisé donnerait forcément envie
à des petites filles de pousser la porte
d'un club alors géraldine est ce qu'il y
a déjà eu un tour de france féminin
officiel eh bien oui et le premier
c'était en 1955 un donc premier tour de
france des hommes 1903 premier tour de
france des femmes 1955 donc il a fallu
attendre un petit peu un tour de france
donc 100% féminin est derrière un homme
un journaliste sportif qui s'appelait
jean leulliot c'est lui qui a décidé de
l'organiser donc c'était un tour tout
comme les garçons 1 avec des étapes avec
du public sur le bord de la route mais
aussi avec des caméras très important
regarder et surtout écouter un le sujet
de l'époque filmer pour le journal des
actualités françaises nouvelles
conquêtes féminines toutes celles une
quarantaine que la gloire de beauvais
fait rêver ce sont soumises aux petite
formalité qui prépare les grands
champions cyclistes les massages dans ce
cas ne sont plus une simple question
d'esthétique et nos courses hier c'est
leur titre officiel le mot coureuses
n'ayant pas été retenue l'eau coursières
donc on accepter la bande de sparadrap
qui doit le raffermir lire
ainsi s'est envolé si l'on peut dire le
premier tour de france cycliste féminin
un tout petit tour de 400 kilomètres
mais qui deviendra grand
[Applaudissements]
avec quelques clichés et quelques mots
qui font sourire c'était il ya quelques
années quand même on voit bien que même
le vocabulaire coureuses coursières
n'est n'est pas adapté 1 vous êtes une
coureuse une coursière une sportive une
championne
tout ça à la fois je pense que c'est
important que les mots soient féminisé
aussi pour pour qu'on existe tout
simplement est ce moi ce qui m'a marqué
j'avais jamais vu mon extrait plus
sérieux alors moi j'emploie le mot de
coureuses voilà mais ce qui est assez
étonnant c'est qu'on parle d'esthétique
en fait alors qu'on parle de sportive et
quand on est une sportive on a envie
qu'on s'intéresse à notre performance
est pas à notre esthétique ou à notre
beauté et c'est vrai que là on l'entend
c'est assez flagrant c'est ce qui
ressort c'est le côté esthétique clair
cette édition 2009 155 très critique et
ne va pas se répéter il faut attendre
1984 pour voir un nouveau tour de france
s'élance et village départ à bobigny en
seine saint denis 18 étapes et une
américaine marianne martin c'est ça qui
s'imposent vous avez couru avec des
cyclistes qui avait participé à ce tour
qu'est-ce qu'elles l'ont elles en disent
de cette époque de ce moment là ils en
parlent encore oui alors marie-françoise
potro qui est actuellement vice
présidente en charge de la féminisation
à la fédération française de cyclisme
est venu rouler avec nous elle a vécu le
tour de france de ces années là ce
qu'elle me racontait c'est que en fait
elles ont été prévenues au tout dernier
moment
elles ont dû se préparer en très peu de
temps quelques semaines avant ils ont
appris qu'elle serait pendant trois
semaines sur les routes du tour ce qui
était une aubaine pour elle un
évidemment elles se sont prêtés au jeu
volontiers mais je pense qu'à cette
époque ça a été la volonté d'une
personne qui avait envie de pousser dans
ce sens là malheureusement ça n'a pas
duré très longtemps alors vous avez fait
avec avec ces jeunes femmes une étape du
tour comment ça se passe sur la route
quels sont vos performances
vous parlez en compétition oui enfin en
compétition en tout cas sur sur 150 180
km oui alors nous nous réalisons les
étapes peut pas sous un format
compétitif le but justement c'est que la
course qui sera organisé soit
destination des coureurs professionnels
pas forcément des cours aux amateurs
comme nous on part sans dossard on prend
le départ ensemble on arrive ensemble et
c'est vraiment un projet militant avec
un message derrière de mixité géraldine
ce tour de france en simultané avec
celui des hommes a eu lieu tous les ans
entre 1984 et 1989 un tour de france
féminin avec moins de kilomètres
regardez le sujet qui était consacré
d'ailleurs lors du premier départ je
crois que le journaliste a même fait un
petit peu d'humour un petit peu oui on
regarde
1984 n'est béni pour les suffragettes
après le tour de france le tour des miss
est à côté des géants de la route voici
les mignonnes du bitume une première
tentative qui sert de test cette année
que les femmes chez eux et éthique
notions en vélo peu importe vous savez
un haltérophile qui soulève de 100 kg
s'est pas non plus très très beau à voir
certaines sont doués en cyclisme et elle
mérite une grande épreuve pour se
combattre
alors juste ben non justement ce tour de
france donc a duré six ans 84 89
on a pu voir sur les mêmes plateaux ce
qui était assez rare des coureuses
c'est minime et des coureurs masculins
des championnes et samassa fait penser à
ça m'a fait penser à cette archive de
1987 où sur un même plateau elle est
connue mais elle est hallucinante donc
je voulais qu'on la revoie ensemble et
qu'on en parle ensemble clair sur un
même plateau donc à 487 il ya marc
madiot star du vélo mais aussi jeannie
longo star du vélo tout de même aussi
qui parle et qui débattent de l'intérêt
du cyclisme féminin on regarde attention
c'est sans filtre c'est complètement
respecté et des sports qui sont malins
et des sports qui sont féminins voir une
femme danse et pour moi c'est très joli
voir une femme joue au football allemand
non mais c'est moi je reconnus par une
femme danse et c'est très joli voir une
fois de jouer au football c'est moche et
josy pouvoir une mauvais voire une femme
sur un bel oxymore jc monde pour ça
n'engage que moi s'il ya des gens qui
trouvent ça bien tant mieux pour eux par
un doublement
jolie sera ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que le sport cycliste est un sport
extrêmement difficile moi j'aime trop
les femmes pour les voir sourire c'est
mon prénom
c'est simple elle est arrachée sur un
vélo c'est ce que
je pense qu'on ne veut pas dire qu'on
aime les femmes quand on ne respecte pas
leurs deux filles ratio comment on ne
peut pas dire ce qu'on aime les femmes
quand on respecte pas leurs aspirations
claires votre réaction en sachant que
cette année la jeannie longo avait gagné
le tour oui alors ou pour moi le sport
n'a pas de sexe donc on peut être une
petite fille allait jouer au foot être
un petit garçon allait faire de la danse
ou aller faire du cycliste quand on est
une petite fille je pense que le fond de
la pensée de marc madiot est pas
forcément beaucoup évolué puisque on a
eu l'occasion de débattre ensemble sur
le sujet du tour de france féminin est
ce qu il en est ressorti c'était en 2017
c'est qu' il fallait que les femmes sont
si on voulait développer notre sport on
s'appuie sur nos caractéristiques les
caractéristiques de notre sexe qui sont
la féminité et le charme on peut aussi
espérer que les mentalités ont évolué et
que les propos de marc madiot
appartiennent au passé la preuve je vais
vous dire géraldine la rédaction dina
s'est prêté à un exercice particulier
ressortir un micro trottoir des années
60 sur ce sujet et reposé la question
cette semaine expliquez-nous oui un donc
en 1968 une journaliste est allé dans la
rue au bistrot interviewé des coureurs
mais aussi des landes à des
esthéticiennes elle leur a demandé
qu'est ce qu'il pensait du cyclisme
féminin et nous ce qu'on a voulu faire
c'est poser exactement les mêmes
questions donc tariq ali et ludivine
lopez sont allés dans les rues
aujourd'hui à paris ont demandé enfin on
poser exactement mot pour mot la même
question aux parisiens et écouter
heureusement ça a un petit peu changé
moi j'ai deux filles je voudrais quand
même pas qu'il fasse du vélo
le cyclisme féminin
jeu magnifique
[Musique]
salon du cyclisme féminin
on va certainement c'est un excellent
sport s'entretient la ligne je ne suis
pas d'accord le collège que les femmes
font dire que pensez-vous du cyclisme
féminin
je trouve ça cher c'est bizarre comme
question tous ces ingrédients fin c'est
une distraction ne peut pas être une
compétition pour les jeunes je trouve
que c'est
pourtant mon père il fait du vélo et
j'ai même pas dû parler on voit jamais
la télé je pense que les femmes ont
toutes l'otan droit de faire du cyclisme
que les hommes je pense qu'on serait
contre
ça donne vraiment le site et ce matin
des sports qui était socialement réservé
aux c'est un sport masculin je pense on
se lance il n'y a pas de sport réservé
aux hommes ou aux femmes il ya le sport
et le pratique selon ses envies ses
capacités son talent c'est tout
je pensais que ça ne leur ôte pas tr min
t sur l'unique pas tout jeune fille sur
un mélange suis pas tellement gracieux
pour le changement maintenant j'espère
que ma femme ne verra pas la vidéo mais
je trouve ça super sexy de me faire du
vélo c'est magnifique est-ce que vous
pensez que ça ne leur ôte pas un peu de
féminité
non vraiment pas c'est une esthétique
ce n'est pas féminin du tout et pour
légende veut que ce soit un rêve pour
les jambes je trouve que ça une femme
gâteau rochelais c'est pas bien et pour
les jambes vous ne pensez pas que ce
soit mauvais
état
je vois pas pourquoi ces sports serait
mauvais pour les jambes au contraire je
pense que ça draine le sang je pense que
c'est beaucoup moins pour la lutte
contre les varices lorsque les faits ont
tout intérêt à en faire part en faire
une 10 iran parce qu'à ce moment là bien
entendu il ya un trop gros développement
des muscles qui nuit à l'esthétique non
c'est très bon pour les gens
je ne comprends pas vos questions
voilà le regard des français sur ce
sujet à travers le temps clair floret
merci à vous et j'espère que votre
combat pour un tour de france féminin va
porter ses fruits en tout cas la
fédération internationale a promis un
nouveau tour de france féminin en 2000
22 voilà pour ce premier numéro de
l'inattendu on se retrouve mercredi
prochain sur le canal 27 à 21 heures et
toute la semaine bien sûr sur les
réseaux sociaux de france télévisions et
de l'ina
[Musique]